hello everyone and welcome to the thermo
Fisher Scientific webinar series on
Sanger sequencing and fragment analysis
made easy corresponding with the launch
of applied Biosystems new seeks to do
genetic analyzer today we present the
fifth topic in the series a complete
workflow for human cell line
identification presented by dr. Steve
Jackson a product applications
specialist for Thermo Fisher Scientific
I'm Suzy Valdez and I'll be your
moderator for today's educational
webinar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by thermo Fisher Scientific
before we begin I'd like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on that green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
your presentation window type your
questions into the box that appear on
this screen I won't answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also notice you are
viewing this presentation in a slide
window to enlarge that window just click
on the screen icon located in the lower
right if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing this presentation click on the
support button at the top right of the
presentation window or use that Q&A
button and let us know you're having a
problem I'd now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Steve Jackson dr.
Jackson has over 10 years of experience
and genetic analysis technologies as a
senior member of the genetic analysis
R&D team at thermo Fisher Scientific he
helps develop solutions for this
research and health care markets
leveraging very technologies such as
capillary electrophoresis digital PCR
next-generation sequencing and micro
array analysis please join me in
welcoming dr. Jackson I will now turn
the presentation over to him welcome sir
Thank You Sussie and thank you everybody
for joining us today I'm going to talk
about cell line authentication and human
sample authentication I'm specifically
going to talk about the solutions that
thermo Fisher has available for making
sure that cell lines and your human
samples are exactly what you think they
are so next slide please so selling
authentication is basically confirming
the cells that you have growing in your
culture dish are what you think that
they are this is usually done by
comparison comparing two databases such
as a TCC the DSM Z in Europe or the
Rican databases in Japan and making sure
that the the tests that you do for the
cells growing in your culture are either
matching with what you have previously
established or they match up with what
these databases say it's important for
when you establish the provenance of
cell of new cell lines for example when
you make a new tumor cell line in your
in your sample dish you passage it for
awhile you want to make sure that at the
end of that passage in time that what
you have is the same as what you started
off with
so Stephanie province of new cell lines
is very important authentication is also
important when you want to track human
tumors ena graphs and mouse models and
this is making sure that the the tumor
that you have is to write from the human
cell and it's not the mouse so so
indication or the solutions are gonna
prevent from present to you are
important for tracking the Xenia graphs
and mice and finally for some of the ex
vivo research applications that are
coming up induced pluripotent stem cells
and that Carty research you want to make
sure that the differentiated or the
mid-late cells that you have will match
up with your donor before they are
reintroduced into the donor when doing
research for these ex vivo cell
therapies so again doing cell ions
indication human sample authentication
is extremely important for making sure
what you have in your dish or in your
test tube is what you think that it is
why is this so important well it turns
out that there are umpteen
over 500 cell lines that have been
misidentified and over 700 publications
have been made with this one cell lines
MBA MD 435 cell line was originally
described as a breast cancer cell line
but upon further examination it was
later determined to be a melanoma cell
on this is done by expression analysis
and they found that it wasn't expressing
breast epithelial markers is expressing
melanoma markers so there are over 700
publications that are made with this
cell line that have been misidentified
people have been using this as a model
for breast cancer for a long time and it
just is not correct so that's just one
example out of many that are currently
being dealt with with the research
community right now it's a very big
problem and it's getting to be so big
that that NIH and several publications
are acquiring a cell line validation
approach when submitting grants are
submitting publications a growing list
of publications are shown here these
these journals are requiring that they
have provided some kind of authenticity
test for the cell lines they have and
I'm preventing you from publishing
results that are resulting from cell
lines that have been misidentified again
the list is growing and it is going to
be a large apartment in the future as as
did problem is becoming more recognized
so the way
the cell line are most commonly
authenticated or human samples on
indicators using a DNA profile this is
derived from forensic methods that are
used to differentiate different
individuals based on their genotypes at
highly variable low side Illustrated
here are some of the low sigh on the
different chromosomes the the the either
the real name like tea pox FG ACS FPO or
the the more arcane the designation of D
to s 1338 etc these are highly variable
low side that can be used to make a
monthly fingerprint for individuals and
for individual samples as well these
loci are based on short tandem repeats
or STRs
these are microsatellite regions and
without two to five nucleotides that are
repeated several times in tandem they're
highly polymorphic they don't really
change the gene expression function but
they do basically provide a way to tag
what is present at a particular locus
the allele length is determined by the
number of repeat units that is shown
here is one allele has seven repeats and
the other allele has eight repeats these
can be analyzed by using labeled alga
nucleotides that flank the the the locus
and provide after amplification
different sized fragments that can be
used to see what is present in the
sample
Thermo Fisher Scientific has developed a
couple of different methods for doing
this with highly multiplex PCR looking
at between 16 and 24 different loci and
a single time and this provides a highly
specific fingerprint for individuals
samples it's also standardized methods
that's useful in forensic analysis and
is part of human identification whoops
so the way that it works is that you
start off with an allelic ladder I
apologize for this there's this is a
screenshot from one of our experiments
where each one of the different grade
out bars shows a different fragment
length and in this allelic ladder what
we have are different Peaks that
correspond to different different
fragment lengths for example in this
first in this first locus here we have a
variety of different Peaks that range
from small to larger sizes the peak size
then is corresponding to different
number of repeats in that STR locus in
it we have a separate locus which is a
little bit larger fragments and again we
can then match up the number of Peaks
the size of the peaks of the present in
the sample
with with what is known from the STR
profile we also have three other
different dyes which we provide a
different family of Peaks for a total of
16 different low-side if the large
number different Peaks for each locus
and in this particular kit to identify
the cell line to authenticate with k2
cell lines it's a fairly simple task to
basically run the same multiplex PCR and
compare the peaks that you get in the
PCR with what you've got in the allelic
ladder okay again here we're showing
this d-4s I think what every good the
designation is here there's a single
peak at this one to your size indicating
this for this individual at this.look is
homozygous for the STR that has a legal
length of say 13 in this case here and
this particular locus this individuals
heterozygous because they have two
different sized Peaks indicating if
there's two different sized STRs at that
particular locus so by going through and
using the different low side then you
can generate a cell line profile that is
unique reductive your cell line so
Thermo Fisher Scientific has two
different types of kits available for
doing this we have the identifier series
and global filer
identify ler series consists of
identified A+ and identify their direct
these are five different dot it dies the
query 16 different low sigh these cover
all of the low side that are used at 18
cc Rican and DSM Z for checking the
attendees authenticity of the cells at
your querying we also have a kit called
global filer this is based on six
different dyes having 24 different low
side that provides an extra level of
discrimination
now these extra low side that are
present our outside of what a TCC
provides but it the kit provides extra
sex determination both side and it
provides a higher degree of
specification since they're more or less
either inquiry and is therefore
excellent for building up your own
database of new and novel cell lines so
the identify lerp lust and global filer
kids both that can be used for cell line
and human sample authentication for the
identifier plus kit it's based on
purified DNA the workflow is shown here
at the top of the screen here you start
off by isolating genomic DNA using a
favorite kit of course demo Fisher
Scientific has options for for isolating
genomic purified genomic DNA you then
amplify using identifier kit identified
a plus kit run the the samples by
climate analysis on steeps who seeks to
do or one of our other couple of other
Larry electrophoresis instruments and
analyze using gene mapper now to show
with this how this works are basically
purified genomic DNA from five different
cell lines and analyze them on seeks to
do on our 3,500 instrument and 3130
instruments I use varying their amounts
of DNA
ranging from three nanograms down 2.1
nanograms and what i want to point out
from this is that using purified DNA if
you use too much of it you can wind up
getting reduced efficiency because of
their being
excess Peaks in spurious Peaks that are
present the identifier a plus kit is
meant to use one mana gram or less and
here we see that for one nanogram on
3130 instruments we get
perfect calling frequency and down at
three men appointee nanograms therapy
three grams or less would get perfect
falls on seeks to do you know we wind up
getting out of range errors and spurious
Peaks because the extra sensitivity and
using the seek studio instruments using
less than one nanogram can certainly be
tolerated provide accurate results here
so one nanogram is recommended we also
recommend doing a PCR cycle number test
to make sure that you are within that
the range and not producing out of range
errors by using between 27 and 29 cycles
of PCR they identify their direct kits
make use of these nucleic cards these
are our cards that have a DNI state DNA
stabilizing matrix built into them so
all you have to do is basically spot the
cells onto these cards as shown here let
this lift is the cells dry on the card
there and take a small punch from where
the cells have been spotted on the card
and analyze the punch directly without
having to purify genomic DNA on these
work these are made to be used for blood
samples but they work extremely well
using the cell line growth minutes so in
this in this workflow to do is you take
yourselves who spot them on the nucleic
cards amplify that the spot directly
using identify the direct analyze by
fragment analysis and gene mapper
software so to show how these were done
I hearts of cells in PBS has spotted 100
microliters of the PBS solution onto
these nucleic cards that's at one point
two millimeter punches of different
pollutions and analyze them using bit
identifiers direct kit how much you can
see is that by using about five times
ten to the fifth seed cells we get you
know a perfect calling of the alleles in
these different cell types by using a
tenfold dilution we're still able to
call a vast majority of the cells on
seeks to do 3,500
we start to get some dropouts in the
thirty-one
30 I'm going to use a hundred fold
solutions we're getting a small number
of also detected so we recommend that
you spot at least 5 times 10 to the 5th
cell onto these cope and player cards
for that using identify their direct
occupations so one of the things that
that the kits can allow you to do is
detect whether or not you have
contaminated cells here so what I'm
showing in this case here is a HeLa cell
line that was mixed with this m4a4 gfp
cell if you know what this what the
profile is for say for example these M
for a full GFP cells you can recognize
which alleles are coming from the HeLa
cells and are not part of what the m4a4
GFP profile is this allows you to say
that if you're seeing your three peaks
or peaks in multiple loci it's possible
that the cell lines that you are using
have become contaminated the second cell
line so to show how this works then what
I did was I took up different amounts of
HeLa cells mix them with the m4a4 GFP
cells and PBS spotted them on the Copan
cards dried them and then analyzed
punches after drying overnight by PCR
and so you can see here that on at 50%
mixture a one-to-one mixture of HeLa
cells and for a for GFP cells you're
getting a perfect detection of the HeLa
cells all the HeLa cells alleles that
are present that makes population even
at 20% at HeLa cells and one to five
mixture of HeLa cells you're able to
detect a vast majority of the HeLa cell
specific alleles that are present but
even down at ten percent and one to ten
dilution of the HeLa cells into the end
to the m4a4 GFP cells you can still see
that over half of the of the allele
specific HeLa cells can be detected on
the 3,500 and seeks to do instruments so
these a unique aleosis can be detected
in around ten to fifteen percent of a
population but with highest confidence
you can did you can tell which cells are
contending if they're present around
twenty percent of the population and
you're in the ditch
now using purified genomic DNA you can
go down even lower in this case I spiked
in Gila d8 purified DNA into m4a4 gfp
DNA down to 1% and even at 1% i was able
to detect about 1/5 of the Gila cell
specific low side that I expect here on
6 to do so what this is saying is that
you know over half the cell of HeLa cell
specific low site can be detected at 4
percent of the of the contaminating DNA
even down to 1% of the DNA
you can still see HeLa specific loci and
and point that yourselves that points in
the fact that your cells might be
contaminated with different cell type
and we expect so one of the
characteristics about cells grown in
culture for a while is that they are
genetically unstable and you can wind up
having peak sizes that are different
sizes this is this is a little bit
different than than in forensic analysis
because in forensic analyses it was
sample is homozygous or heterozygous you
expect there to be
peak sizes of equal representation and
cell lines though because you mean you
can have this genomic instability you
can see that that you have peak heights
that are different representations
indicate there's different abundances of
cells have different STR profiles
present so as long as you as you see
this from the outset you can you can
identify that the cells that have
different peak heights that might have
arised from Tremec instability so to
show that this is the case here and the
kit is working effectively
I took one nanogram Ishinomaki name from
hapmap samples and from cell lines
analyzed them using identified a direct
kick on 3500 and I calculated the ratio
of the peak hikes that are present and
at each of the particular locus which
expect is that if a sample is perfectly
heterozygous that you get a peak height
of 1 or if the if the sample is
homozygous I just defined that as being
1 so I'm showing here is that we have 16
different loci
in this case whoops in this case I'm
looking at a male a genin and here you
can see that in the samples that are hat
man on the on this side of the green
line we're getting peak ratios that are
exactly 1.0 but in the cell lines that
are on the Left I'm sorry on the right
of the green line you can see that there
are ratios that are quite a bit
different from 1.0 and this is true for
the different low-side that are present
here for example here in this case here
we again the the hapmap samples on the
left of the green line are showing about
one but two the the cell lines are
showing ratios in this case of about 2
indicating éclairs of duplication in
HeLa cells I mistook your locus yes so
the different different cell lines
there's another example here where this
particular locus is quite variable in
the cell lines but again pretty uniform
in the the hapmap samples obtained from
individual so allelic imbalance is
detectable using the east kits it's
likely the result of passing the cells
from many lines in vitro and it's more
evident cell lines than in samples
derived from from humans that have not
been caster's in the culture okay so in
addition to being able to analyze cell
lines and authenticating cell lines
these kids can be used for
authenticating human samples and other
types of experimentation so in this case
here we just want to verify that a
sample derived from the individual is
indeed matches to the donor in this case
here what we're doing what we've done is
taking buccal swabs from whoops buccal
swabs buccal swabs from an individual
and t-cells from individual putting them
onto nucleic carts and getting in a
profile of the car of the of the alleles
present in these different samples and
you can see we're just showing one of
the channels here from the global filer
kit here and you can see that an in the
blue channel that we get a perfect match
of the of the t-cells to what we got
from the original buccal cells giving us
confidence than the B that the T cells
actually came from individual in
question another way to look at this is
by making sure that induced pluripotent
stem cells match up with the donors in
this case we collected blood samples
from from from donors stem cells were
collected from the blood samples they
were cultured to differentiate it and
then we collected DNA from the original
blood sample collection and from the new
score potent stem cells
we then randomized blinded the stem
cells and our collaborator sent them to
me for analysis
I took one nanogram the DNA and analyzed
them using identify the + and calculated
an allelic score which is just in the on
on the most general case and the legal
score was simply the sum as all alleles
allelic numbers that are present in the
sample and then this small set I was
able to match it
yulik scores from the induced cells with
the original blood samples here so for
example here in this individual or in
this in this case here we had an allelic
score of 415 point two again that's just
the sum of the allelic numbers for each
one a different low side present here
and I was able to match the the blood to
the IPS ES and that individual based on
this similarity of the scores here
here's another example here another
collection from a different individual
here getting a different allele explore
here and again I was quickly able to
match up the IPS ES with the blood from
that from that individual in this case
here we had 24 different donor
collections different blood and IPS CS
roughness individuals and they matched
up perfectly so one thing I want to say
from this is that the allelic score is
is a good measure of looking of matching
up
individuals on a small sample set but of
course new look at larger sample sets
you can get scores that are the same but
they're derived from different different
allelic numbers at different loci so on
larger data sets you might want to look
at a different way of analyzing when we
look score other than just to grow some
so we're often asked when is the best
time to authenticate so we recommend
authenticating when you're establishing
the provenance of a new cell line when
you're just starting off at an
experiment at the very low passage
number for example you want to take an
alcohol of the cells generate a a
profile of those cells before you do
anything further and this is especially
useful when you want compare profiles of
a of a normal to non-cancerous reference
you know from the get-go from the start
you won't be able to have profile screen
you can quickly see whether or not the
cells are what you think that they are
it's also important to authenticate
meaning when you get an existing cell
line from either a collaborator or from
one of the the cell line repositories
that are available we know that that
some of the cell lines that are present
in these repositories have been
misidentified we want to you know make
sure that that cell line you get from
individual or from a from a a collection
is is authentic and so you would want to
to make a profile since you get those
cells you know in again at a low passage
number to make sure they are correct
from the start
we'd also want to generate profiles over
the course of your workflow to make sure
that the cells are remaining what you
think they are over the course of your
your work it'd be a good idea to after
each passage number to take a an aliquot
IV's and again validate that they are
genuine and they are they match up with
what the initial profile was and again
when you when you get a cell line you
might want to get a baseline
profile of yourselves before continuing
our before pursuing other experiments so
that in the end you can test the cells
in the very end and that's they and make
sure they match with what you generated
very beginning of your workflows so to
conclude here what I've shown you is
that short kind of repeat sequences can
be useful Marcus were authenticating
human cell lines I've alluded to the
fact the seeks to do is greater that
provides greater sensitivity row up to
thirty five hundred and thirty one
thirty platforms and that simply means
that you can use less DNA or fewer PCR
cycles relative to the other platforms
on a seeks to do instrument they
identify their plus kit can be used as
little as three hundred P grams of
genomic DNA to authenticate cell lines
and as little as five times some of the
v cells per mil of a suspension can be
used if the Copan nucleic cards can
identify their direct kit without having
to purify a genomic DNA from those up
from your cells and finally I've shown
you the contaminant contaminating cells
can be identified if they make up at
least twenty percent of the cell culture
population but unique alleles can be
identified from contaminating cells in
as little as one to five percent if
you're just looking at at single unique
low alleles that in that mixed
population you might not generate a
complete profile but you can detect
connect containing alleles in some cases
as little as 1% to the population so
finally I'd like to thank dr. David
Yoder for his help in generating the the
cell line workflows and the data and on
the the need for authenticating cell
lines let's think comedy vomit at Pharma
and her team for for helping out with
the work described in this presentation
and we also want to emphasize that the
products are not sold for science
indication in China Hong Kong or Japan
they're only used for forensics and
prepare use in those countries so thank
you very much for your time and we'd be
happy to answer questions now
okay
so let me go to the questions that we
have received so one of the questions
that we have gotten was whether or not
the methods described here will work for
frozen cells and for FFPE tissues and
the answer is yes
fortunately the identifiers work it's
the gold flower kicks
we're designed to work with forensic
samples which are often highly degraded
DNA and so the amplicons and the
low-side that have been chosen are
specifically used for looking at a
degraded DNA in cleansing samples and
therefore quite applicable to FFPE
samples and other examples were that the
DNA from your cell lines have been
degraded or are less than perfect
quality so yes the the global fiber
identifier kicks in the workflows
presented here will work a few samples
another question that we have received
is that the Sikhs through that we've
talked about in this presentation what
are the benefits of the Sikhs to do
there's people that want to know a
little bit more about what it does so
this instrument is a new personal
capillary electrophoresis instrument if
you will it is designed to be extremely
easy to use we have completely
redesigned the user interface so that
you can set up runs access data and
analyze the runs quickly and easily
we've designed to be extremely easy to
use and that there's instead of having
different arrays and polymers and
buffers that are needed to be added to
the instrument everything is contained
within a single cartridge the cartridge
is a simply plug and play and so you can
put the cartridge in the Machine and
immediately start using this provides
advantages because the the cartridge
itself is stable on the instrument and
it at four degrees for four months so
you can use the same explained cartridge
over and over and over again and save it
for quite a while and it also allows
users to swap out cartridges so that
different labs don't have to too
cannibalize each other's resources if
you will the other thing is that we have
made the suit a studio to be a network
friendly from the get-go so that you can
access the film official cloud and on
remote devices control the instrument
near the runs etc remotely this allows
individuals then to share their data
with their collaborators with other
users and you know share data more
easily the cartridge itself not to
mention is for capillaries so we have to
say that the veenstra itself is not
necessarily high-throughput but it is
meant for those those smaller labs for
those situations where maybe a high
throughput instrument is overkill but we
still need to get good high quality data
from the gold standard of pepper
literature provides another question
just come in is what other ways are
there to authenticate cell lines besides
using STR markers so on that there
certainly can be done using snips and
this is most usually done by layout by
NGS solution so you would basically
generate a snip profile using
next-generation sequencing it certainly
is possible to do that and it provides a
lot of data but in some cases that might
just be overkill unless you have a very
high throughput it sometimes it's more
expensive to do this by next-gen
sequencing and you get a lot of data
that you might not necessarily need to
address the questions you're asking it
just simply is that are these cells you
know what I think they are so in some
cases next-gen sequencing as snip tag
analysis is appropriate in other cases
the STR analysis there's probably better
route to go because it is much quicker
it provides the same level of
specificity that it s snip profile might
didn't provide see in their scenarios to
recommend direct work for Flip's li
authentication
so I mentioned in the talk that there
are two different ways that you can
analyze cell cell lines and Windham
samples one is by using the gun Defiler
plus and when I've done to further
direct identifiers quest requires
genomic DNA for purification for the
beste are purified genomic DNA for the
best results identified a Direct Connect
use of punches on on these nucleic cards
without having purified DNA so my own
personal preference is that I like the
identify low direct workflow because it
is so much easier you don't have to go
through their entire DNA purification
step and also the cards themselves are
stable for a very long time for at least
a year and so you can spot the cards
spot that your cells on to the cards
store them in room temperature for a
long time and then go back to the car
just necessary to to repeat or to
reanalyze the cell lines define a period
of time they also pick up very much
space and so that it's very easy to
store data samples on nucleotides is
this workflow ethical for frozen tissue
fragments in addition to cell lines and
the answer is yes basically you can do
the same workflow to match up any human
samples again the the kits have been
designed to work with forensic samples
and provide a very precise
identification of individuals so if you
want to match up human samples the
identifiers and global politics are
ideal
ways to go because they provide house to
the fingerprints of the samples and on
the very very very extremely low
likelihood that samples from different
individuals you won't have the same STR
profile so it looks like
that's all the questions that we have
come I'll come in the webinar itself
would be available download download
through June 2018 so please revisit the
cyclic or direct your friends and
colleagues to decide if you need to have
more information and finally we thank
you very much for your time and your
interest and utopia from you soon good
day